- We have just enough time
for one more great story.
This is "What I'm Liking."
Many of you probably remember
the hit TV show "Quantum Leap"
with Scott Bakula.
Each week he'd leap into a
new body and solve problems
with the help of Al, the hologram,
and a computer, named Ziggy.
It was the eighties people. It made sense.
Now quantum leap is back,
this time with a new cast,
and it premieres tonight. Check it out.
- Okay. I think it's time
for that slower explanation.
- Your name is Dr. Ben Zong.
You're a time traveler from the year 2022.
I'm Addison, Augustine.
We are-
We work together.
Look, I'm here to bring
you home, but to do that-
(Static)
- To what?
Need to what?!
- Please welcome the
star of "Quantum Leap",
Raymond Lee everybody!
So, welcome to the show.
- Thank you so much for having me big fan.
- I mean, no, I'm a big fan.
I'm so stoked about this.
So it's not actually like a
remake. It's a sequel, right?
- It is. It's a continuation
from the original.
It's 30 years after Dr. Sam Beckett
jumped into quantum accelerator
and vanished forever,
And now, a new team has been assembled to
uncover the mysteries,
And I am part of that new team.
- This is-
like me-
me and my mom- I mean,
it's gonna be our jam.
I'm so excited.
Were you a fan of the original?
Cuz you're too young to
have been watching it
when it was on.
- Yeah, I, I, I am
indeed and I was indeed.
My best friend in sixth
grade, this was his jam,
And before I was only into like,
Xmen, Ninja Turtles.
- Just cartoons. - Nothing
wrong with turtle power.
- Nothing wrong with turtle power.
But I also wasn't into like, watching
like humans do things.
I was into watching cartoons, do things.
And he introduced me
to this and I was like,
"my life is forever changed."
It was my first introduction to sci-fi.
- I love sci-fi.
So have you met Scott Bakula?
- I have not. I would love to whenever.
- Okay. I wonder what he thinks.
I don't know. Just curious.
- I hope he likes. I hope he likes it.
I, you know what? I'm
just, let's just filter it.
He loves it.
- He loves it. He loves it.
- He just told me. Just now.
- Okay, good.
- He's like such a fan.
- Thanks Scott.
- I'm very excited about this. Thank you.
I love when shows come out
that I get so excited about watching.
So thank you for doing that.
I love being entertained.
- Thank you for having me.
So happy to here. Thank you.
- You can catch the premier
of "Quantum Leap" tonight
at 10:00 PM on NBC and streaming
the next day on Peacock.
- That's what me and my mom were doing, so
Raymond, I'm liking your post right now.
- Awesome.
Want to celebrate the next
generation of scientists
people who inspire shows
like "Quantum Leap.:
So they're writing a check
for a thousand dollars
to code.org,
A nonprofit dedicated to
bringing computer science
to all students
Which is so rad. Thank you so much!